[Music]  I've been spending the summer doing a  lot of zoo promotions parrots live a  very long time so we had a birthday  party for a parent that turned sixty  chimpanzees are very smart so we had  them graduate from college and they like  to fling their feces so we were hoping  that they would fling their hats but  they swung their feces the Pawnee Zoo  recently purchased two South African  black-footed penguins tux and flipper  and as part of our zoo promotion we are  going to give them a marriage ceremony  because they mate for life tux  do you take flipper to be your lawfully  wedded wife I do I do  by the power vested in me from the  Department of Parks and Recreation I now  pronounce you husband and wife  Oh okay well at least you're married  making babies no not those two those are  both boy penguins  I'm sorry tuxie flipper are both boys so  you should have pronounced them husband  and husband technically that's awesome  you